diplomats met in Paris for another
attempt at finding a solution to the
Gaza conflict the foreign ministers of
Turkey and Qatar were present since both
have some degree of influence over Hamas
US Secretary of State John Kerry wants
them to act as mediators he cannot talk
to Hamas directly because Washington
considers the Palestinian group to be a
terrorist organization afterwards Kerry
said he hoped that efforts could be made
towards reaching a sustainable ceasefire
we clearly understand I understand that
Palestinians need to live with dignity
with some freedom with goods that can
come in and out and they need a life
that is free from the current restraints
that they feel on a daily basis and
obviously free from violence but at the
same time Israelis need to live free
from rockets and from tunnels that
threaten them and every conversation
we've had embraces a discussion about
these competing interests that are real
for both his French counterpart lohan
fog use made a similar appeal juice dr.
Neil all of us want to reach a lasting
ceasefire as early as possible noguchi
one that addresses Israel's needs in
terms of security and the Palestinians
needs in terms of economic and social
development as well as access to the
territory of Gaza we could a week a duck
see would delete well together Israel
has approved a short extension to the
temporary truce